la nouvelle tombe le 8 septembre comme
le veut la tradition c'est sur les
grilles du palais de Buckingham que se
fait l'annonce de la mort de la reine
meurt dans son château à Balmoral en
Écosse
puis c'est le va et vient des membres de
la famille royale certains d'entre eux
n'arriveront pas à temps
déjà les premiers bouquets de fleurs
apparaissent au pied des grilles du
domaine en Écosse
puis au palais de Buckingham une mère de
fleurs pour la reine avec des messages
personnels pour celles qui aura régné
pendant 70 ans une nouvelle redoutée
même si elle avait 96 ans l'annonce de
sa mort a pris les Britanniques de cours
deux jours avant elle recevait la
nouvelle Première ministre du
Royaume-Uni les Strauss dans son salon à
Balmoral
le 10 septembre Charles III est
officiellement proclamé roi au palais
Saint-James c'est la première fois que
la cérémonie historique et télévisée
c'est en Écosse que le cercueil de la
reine serait exposé au public pour la
première fois un rappel symbolique que
l'Écosse est toujours une nation
importante au sein du Royaume-Uni puis
cinq jours après le décès de la reine
c'est le rapatriement de la dépouille à
Londres accompagné par la princesse Anne
[Musique]
une musique funèbre rythmée par le bruit
des bottes
sous un soleil radieux le cortège quitte
le palais de Buckingham la résidence
officielle de la reine pendant 70 ans il
y a encore trois mois elle saluait la
foule du fameux balcon pour les
célébrations de son jubilé de platine
une procession préparée depuis des
décennies rien n'est laissé au hasard
75 pas par minute pendant près de 40
minutes
le roi Charles la princesse Anne le
prince Anjou déchu de ses titres royaux
et militaires et le prince Edward
accompagne la procession derrière les
petits-enfants de la reine le prince
William et Harry uni dans le deuil un
moment émouvant qui rappelle le décès de
leur mère il y a 25 ans il suivait le
cercueil de la princesse Diana 500
soldats en tout pour accompagner la
procession placé sur un affût de canon
le cercueil est recouvert de l'étendard
royal la couronne d’état impériale ornée
de près de 3000 diamants et de pierres
précieuses la foule est émue pendant 10
km le cortège traverse les grandes
avenues de Londres
où sont des applaudissements de la foule
et des tirs de canon de raid Park
pendant quatre jours des centaines de
milliers de Britanniques feront la files
pour se recueillir sur le cercueil de la
reine exposé à westminsterall la tante
était parfois de 24 heures le moment est
historique
Elisabeth II aura avoué sa vie à la
couronne royale et son peuple aura tenu
à lui dire merci